l'objectif pour nous bien entendu c'est
de remettre un outil neuf à disposition
qui sera en face première visite avec
monsieur le maire pour l'un des trois
derniers candidats retenus à 35 ans
julien possède une bonne expérience dans
la restauration
il veut désormais retrouver son
indépendance j'ai une entreprise en sus
donc de chef à domicile
j'ai eu des employés c'est vrai que
depuis je suis venu arrivée en france
bas
j'ai toujours été motivé par l'envié de
me remettre mon compte et je veux dit
que vu l'investissement qui que la
commune fait je pense que pour le
professionnel qui s'établira ici je
penserai une bonne une bonne opportunité
bien connu à saint vite le soleil d'or
s'est éteint en 2015
racheté par la mairie en 2016 la partie
restaurant sera rénové cet état alors là
nous sommes actuellement dans le hall
d'accueil et le bar du restaurant un
piano flambant neuf et tous les
équipements de cuisine seront installés
reste à sélectionner le meilleur
candidat
nous avons scindé le bâtiment vendu en
quatre logements la partie hôtel et
conserver le restaurant pour aujourd'hui
lancé notre masterchef et trouver un
vrai professionnel à une personne
vraiment dynamique qui a envie de
s'éclater sur saint vite et surtout de
nous apporter la restauration que tout
le monde attend sur sa vie puisque nous
sommes très très peu fourni en matière
de restauration
première étape aujourd'hui pour les
futurs chefs d'entreprise un entretien
avec des professionnels puis le 29 juin
prochain une épreuve pratique en cuisine
avec un menu à réaliser pour les
papilles averti du jury ouverture prévue
du restaurant en septembre prochain